en el estado de la florida en eeuu se
lleva a cabo la fase de sentencia al
juicio nicolás cruz el autor de la
matanza ocurrida en 2018 en una escuela
secundaria de parkland la fiscalía pidió
la pena de muerte para el acusado por
los asesinatos atroces y crueles de 17
personas el fiscal alegó que en este
caso hay hasta siete factores agravantes
que justifican esta pena de muerte para
cruz entre ellos los múltiples las
múltiples víctimas la crueldad que
mostró y también la planificación de ese
ataque pero estos factores agravantes lo
constituye el vídeo en el que el joven
alertó tres días antes de que sería el
próximo autor de un tiroteo en una
escuela que tenía que tenía como
objetivo matar a 20 personas armados con
un fusil semiautomático
ar-15 salvamos entonces a nuestra
segunda invitada del día ella es maribel
balbín ella es representante de la
organización free ver ni con el violence
en florida gracias
maribel por estar con nosotros esta
mañana en directo américa de france 24
de preguntó entonces que implicaría una
condena
a capital tanto para las familias de las
víctimas como para también otros casos
de violencia armada en el país
y muy buen día muchas gracias por la
invitación
en el proceso que se está llevando a
cabo hoy día es muy complicado de 20
este s con excede declaró culpable por
lo tanto ya tenía los cargos sobre él
pero la ley que quiere que una vez que
se pide la pena de muerte tengamos este
proceso es bien fuerte para las familias
que estuvieron ayer en la corte tener
que estaban poniendo los vídeos que
algunos de los estudiantes tomaron
durante la masacre y luego cuando se
oyen los gritos de los estudiantes los
familiares tuvieron que irse de la corte
lo que era no podían resistir no el de
la presentación que estaba llevando a
cabo
pero es requerida por la ley entonces
este juzgado lo que está haciendo ahora
que va a tener que hoy por meses que se
supone que este caso va a durar
y entonces decidir si este niño debe
morir o debe estar en cadena perpetua
son 17 cargo así que son 17 casi cadenas
perpetuas y el jurado tiene que decidir
unánimemente o sea si un solo de los
jurados dice que no está de acuerdo con
algo pequeño
inmediatamente entonces no se puede
hacer lo que es la condena
a morir se adelanta la pena capital así
que es bien complicado y lo más lo peor
como te decía al principio es que la
comunidad tiene que pasar ahora
nuevamente sobre toda la tragedia toda
la pena y todo el dolor que estas
familias pasaron durante este este alto
no también maribel luego ese tiroteo en
el año 2018 nació el movimiento match
for life que nació tras este tiroteo de
parwan que alcancé ha tenido digamos
alguna presión contra el gobierno tanto
local como federal para que realmente
pues intensifique la seguridad en los
colegios en las escuelas que sean
lugares seguros para obviamente pues las
personas que realmente están las
autoridades tras este hecho también que
lamentablemente y vimos otro hace poco
en balde en texas
definitivamente cuando sucedió de cuarta
en la presión de la comunidad y las
víctimas la familia de las víctimas hizo
que en la florida se adoptarán unas
leyes muy específicas las cuales creemos
que han causado efecto porque obviamente
no hemos tenido otro un acto similar o
parecido y por lo tanto si la presión de
este momento de las familias causó de
que la ley cambiará y se debe
implementar una ley de la florida
de la misma forma esos mismos grupos
marchar al live the mothers team and
action que son un grupo de madres desde
edad cuando fue la matanza de charly de
sal dijo que soy tanto tiempo atrás esos
grupos han puesto mucha presión también
ahora al nivel federal y vimos que por
primera vez en dos décadas se ha podido
pasar una ley federal aunque no contiene
todos los detalles que tiene la ley de
la florida ni lo que las personas
quieren si por lo menos es un primer
paso
para ver cómo se controla esta tragedia
que obviamente raúl también es algo que
sugiere a los eeuu vemos que esto no
sucede en otros lugares del mundo claro
maribel y precisamente sobre esa nueva
ley de armas digamos que ya afirmó el
presidente yo vaivén hace unas semanas
atrás es realmente suficiente porque no
se termina de hacer más con tanta
tragedia que hay en eeuu también en
indiana como lo hicimos hace poco una
persona introducción de comercial y
audio abrió fuego sino si no estoy mal
mató también a tres personas pues
todavía no se sabía muy bien las causas
por la que lo hizo pero pues algo
repetitivo en eeuu
repetitivos y vemos que por ejemplo la
única diferencia que existe entre el
resto del mundo es que aquí existen
estas armas y existe la facilidad para
adquirir este tipo de armas un rifle de
asalto no tiene ninguna cabida en una
comunidad y a una persona que no tiene
que no está en la guerra osea estas
armas son diseñadas para matar y matar
de una forma bien horrible o sea vemos
los resultados de los cuerpos de estos
niños en o valdés como tu mencionaba que
fuera cosa horrible de la forma que esta
estos estas armas pues atacan al cuerpo
humano por lo tanto la diferencia existe
en eso en este país hay demasiadas armas
es más que hay más armas que personas en
realidad
a los difícil que resolver porque porque
sea la persona se atienen a lo que son
los derechos de la constitución y este
problema que tenemos con la enmienda 2
que se interpreta tan ampliamente
pues protege a todas estas personas que
quieren tener armas ahora no es que se
nos no se tengan armas sino que no deben
estar en las manos de las personas que
tienen problemas y es lo que hemos visto
que todas estas personas son personas
con problemas y entonces tienen un arma
para satisfacer cualquier persona
psicológico que tienen y tenemos una
víctima entonces en otro lado y también
en personas adolescentes digamos que
incluso no terminan de ser mayores de
edad escasamente alcanzan los 18 o 20
años y eso también quería llegar yo a
nivel pedagógico que pudiera ser que
pudiera hacer la educación de eeuu para
para mitigar el riesgo de que estas
personas con algún tipo de problema
mental evidentemente pues no lleven a
cabo esta lo que quisieran digamos como
estas matanzas que hemos visto en los
colegios
así es y se está haciendo mucho y
específicamente yo te puedo hablar con
la florida por ejemplo existe un
problema un programa muy específico que
se llama evaluación de comportamiento de
riesgo o sea que los maestros los
trabajadores sociales los psicólogos en
las escuelas pueden identificar a un
niño con problemas y estamos pensando
que si lo podemos tratar a una edad
temprana se pueden evitar estos
problemas en el futuro esta ley que se
pasó federalmente que estaba aquí en la
florida que se llama red flag que es
cuando una familia o la comunidad puede
identificar a una persona como con
problemas y sabe que tiene armas y lo
puede reportar y las autoridades pueden
actuar en cuanto a establecer un tipo de
prevención con esta persona o sea lo que
se está especulando en estos momentos es
que tenemos todos estos programas de
prevención
podemos en el futuro evitar que un niño
como este específicamente que ver que
tenía una cantidad de problemas
increíbles todo tipo de bullying en aquí
es muy importante y muy horrible estos
niños que se sienten
ah
atacados claros amigos o no aceptados
entonces terminan haciendo este tipo de
lo que hizo este niño cross y lo dijo
muy bien en sus vídeos que lo estaba
haciendo por esas razones claro tensión
raúl es lo que estamos viendo cómo
podemos prevenir si para que los niños
no se vuelvan en este tipo de persona
y así es maribel de cómo también luego
si ustedes después creo que él llamaba a
la ciudadanía activa a estar muy
pendiente de lo que ocurre pues
obviamente cualquier mínimo detalle pues
reportarlo a las autoridades para tratar
de mitigar esta tragedia que realmente
vive la sociedad estadounidense maribel
gracias por su tiempo un gran abrazo
gracias y encantada